Karen Armstrong historian of religion
well um I never intended to be a
historian of religion I my aim was to
become a professor of English literature
in a university but I had a series of
absolute career disasters and found
myself making television programs about
the nature of religion about Christian
history
um and started to discover about other
religious traditions and that was an
absolute eye-opener for me because in
fact the study of other traditions
doesn't necessarily make you want to
convert to another tradition but it
helps you to see your own differently
and expands your outlook so I learnt a
lot from both initially Jewish and
Muslim theologians that had been missing
perhaps from my rather parochial
Catholic upbringing from the rabbi's of
the early Talmudic age I learned that
there's never a last word on God as you
always continue to question even God
Himself can be questioned and you can
keep arguing with one another and there
will be no end to this conversation
about the divine because and no human
expression of God can be ultimate from
the Muslims I learned from the
extraordinary pluralism of the Koran the
fact that the Koran endorses every
single one of the major world faiths and
I was particularly enthralled by the
Sufi tradition the mystical tradition of
Islam which it's quite which is so open
to other religious faiths it's quite
common for a Sufi mystic to cry in
ecstasy that he's neither a Jew a
Christian or a Muslim he's at home
equally in a synagogue a mosque a temple
or a church because when once glimpsed
the divine our ones left these man-made
stinkums behind there's one quotation I
discovered very early in my researches
very early and it just opened huge doors
to me it's by the major Sufi philosopher
and mystic eben Arabi lived in the 12th
and 13th century and is still deeply
studied by Muslims today and it goes
like this do not praise your own faith
exclusively so that you disbelieve all
the rest if you do this you will miss
much good nay you'll miss the whole
truth of the matter god the omnipotent
and omniscient cannot be confined by any
one greed for he says in the Quran
wheresoever ye turn there is the face of
Allah everybody praises what he knows
his God is his own creature and in
praising it he praises himself which he
would not do if he were just but his
dislike is based on ignorance and I
suppose from the time I read that one of
my objectives was to knock down those
barriers of ignorance that hold us back
from that kind of open-hearted
depreciation of the unanimity of the
human quest we fought for the divine
well I didn't leave the faith just when
I left the convent first I left the
convent and that was because I wasn't a
very good nun I could see that I wasn't
going to make it it's very difficult to
be a nun or to live a religious life
it's very difficult to live a life of
total celibacy of a life without any
possessions or material responsibilities
at all or are we towed in total
obedience to somebody else and remain a
mature of hope you've been being and I
knew that I wasn't going to be one of
those there were some nuns in the
convent who were able to do that and
were fulfilled by it but they there were
a lot of others that weren't and I could
see that I was going to go into that
category so with great sorrow I left it
wasn't a wonderful freeing experience
I didn't leap over the wall as we say in
order to travel and wear beautiful
clothes and make lots of money and fall
in love I knew it was going to be awful
and it was awful I'd been in the convent
for seven years from the ages of seven
seventeen years old to 24 that's a very
formative period in anybody's life and I
totally missed the 1960s which were a
huge change in Western social mores I
entered in 1962 and left in 1969 I had
my first Beatles record in 1970 and I'd
never even heard of Vietnam I came out
of my convent I was already at Oxford at
that time and all my fellow students
were protesting against the Vietnam War
and I'd never heard of it there was one
time when we had been told about the
Cuba crisis in 1963 which happened
shortly after I left where after I
entered I should say and we were told
that the end of the world
my and so we were all praying but then
they forgot to tell us that the crisis
was over so for three weeks I we sat
we're expecting Armageddon we were very
isolated and that made it very difficult
for me to make a comeback to the world
because I didn't know what had happened
the society was transformed it was as
though I'd been like Rip Van Winkle who
went to sleep for a hundred years and
came out and found a totally transformed
and unrecognizable world so then I left
I there was never any great moment when
I stalked out of the Catholic Church but
it fell away from me I had tried as I
thought as a nun to open myself to God
and God seemed totally uninterested in
me the heavens remained closed and
opaque I now realized of course that I
had a very very inadequate idea of God I
was expecting clouds departs a little
sort of whisper in my ear and of course
that's not what God is God is not
another being that we're talking about
something much more profound so I I
think I just found increasingly the
whole boat weight of theology and
Theological dogma incredible and God
remained distant and unknowable and I
just sort of drifted away from it
can't say and that's my answer to you we
can't say what God is and and until the
modern period Jewish Christian and
Muslim theologians in the three God
religions all knew that they insisted
that you we had no idea what we meant
when we said that God was good or wise
or intelligent God is not good or wise
or intelligent anyway that we know so
people like Maimonides in the Jewish
tradition eben Cena in the Muslim
tradition Thomas Aquinas in the
Christian tradition insisted that we
couldn't even say that God existed
because our concept of existence is too
far too limited and they would have been
horrified by the ease in with which we
talk about God today when I was a young
girl I had to learn this definition of
God a God is the supreme spirit who
alone exists of himself and is infinite
in all perfections now I always found
that rather dull and I was eight years
old when I learned that and it really
didn't mean very much to me but I now
also think it's incorrect because it
takes it for granted that it's possible
simply to draw breath and define and
that word define means literally to set
limits upon a reality that has to go
beyond anything we can think or know the
trouble with a lot of modern theology
and a lot of modern thinking about God
is that we think of God as a sort of
being like ourselves but bigger and
better with likes and dislikes similar
to our own now as the great Protestant
theologian Paul Tillich said that's an
idolatry that's making a God in our own
image and that's where some of the awful
atrocities of religion happened when
people assume that God shares your likes
and dislikes the Crusaders went into
battle to cry and kill Muslims and Jews
and cried God wills it
that was their battle cry obviously God
willed no such thing Crusaders were
simply
projecting onto a deity they'd created
in their own image and likeness all
their hatred and loathing of these
faiths and made it endorse some of their
most awful prejudices and lethal
prejudices and modern terrorists do the
same and that is why the theologians
insisted before the modern period that
it was really better to approach God
with in silence
in ancient India they developed what I
think is an authentic model of a
theological discourse religious talk
about the ultimate it was called a
Brahma diya competition and the priests
would go out into the forest it this
we're talking about the tenth century
before Christ and they would make a
retreat and put themselves in into a
different frame of mind and that's very
important because you can't talk about
God in the same way as you'd have an
argument with a colleague or discuss an
abstruse point in law or politics or
business you put yourself into the
receptive frame of mind that with which
we approach music or poetry which you
can measure the difference on an honor
on honor neurological scanner and when
they came back the priests would begin
the competition and the Challenger would
kick off and give a description of the
brahman the ultimate reality that lay
way beyond the gods and he would pour
into this definition all that he could
think all his knowledge and insight and
found a verbal formula puzzling illusive
difficult but that's what Brahman is and
then the challenge his opponents would
have to build on that and respond to him
but the person who won the competition
was the person who reduced all his
opponents to silence and it was in that
silence that the Brahman was present the
Brahman was not present in the wordy
definition
I was present only in the stunning
realization of the impotence of speech
at Christian Jewish and Muslim
theologians all developed similar
disciplines similar rituals to help
people realize that when we talk about
God we are at the end of what words and
thoughts can do well nowadays we've
forgotten all about that and we talk
about God as though he was like a boss
or or or somebody you know we ask him to
bless our nation or save our queen or
give us a five-day for the picnic and we
ask we expect him to be on our side in
an election or a war even though our
opponents are also God's children so we
think about that about God far too
easily that's because of a lot of social
intellectual and scientific changes that
have taken place in the Western world
and that has made God very problematic
for a lot of people
it's not what we study it's what we do
religion is a practical discipline and
it's one that we have always done ever
since we humanity appeared on the scene
when Homo sapiens became Homo sapiens
sapiens became a human being we have our
minds very naturally segue into
transcendence we constantly have ideas
and experiences that go beyond what we
can say or know most often these
expressed in art in painting in music
music every day confronts us with the
form of knowing that doesn't depend on
words it know how it is in the symphony
when you're listening to the symphony
the last notes die away
and there's often a beat of silence in
the auditorium before the applause
begins a very full and pregnant silence
oh now theology should bring us to live
into that silence into that pregnant
pause so but religion is a practical
discipline and in the 17th century and
the West we turned it into a head trip
but the it's like dancing or swimming or
driving which you can't learn by texts
you have to get into the car and learn
how to manipulate the vehicle you have
to get into the water and learn against
what seems to be the law of gravity to
float and dancing or athletics takes you
years before you develop a skill but if
you work at it a practicing daily you
can enable your body to do things that
are utterly impossible to an untrained
physique and can and the religions have
found that if you behave in a certain
way if you if you sort of perform
certain rituals that expand your mind
and make you realize that where help you
to segue into trance
sentence and perform certain acts adopt
a certain lifestyle you develop new
capacities of mind and heart just like
the dancer or the athletic or the AFT
that make you into a whole human being
and principal art the one of these
disciplines right across the board in
all the face is compassion the ability
to feel with the other person
has to become a discipline it's
something that you do it's no good
thinking whether you agree with
compassion or not you've just got to do
it just like it's no good agreeing that
it's possible to float you just have to
get into the pool and then you learn it
that it's possible um every single one
of the major world faiths or they we're
talking about Hinduism Buddhism
Confucianism Taoism Judaism Christianity
and Islam have all come to the
conclusion that what holds us back from
our best self is ego selfishness greed
unkindness hatred they're all Springs
from a sense of snorting ego people
don't like us as much people threaten us
and so in various ways we cut them down
to size to enhance ourselves and the
best way of getting rid of that kind of
unkind grasping frightened ego is by
compassion which doesn't mean to feel
sorry for people it means to put
yourself consistently in the position of
another person put it dethroning
yourself from the center of your world
and putting another there and that's
what brings us the religions say into
contact with what we call brahman
Nirvana God or Dao and every single one
of the major world face has developed
its own version of what's now known as
the Golden Rule always treat all others
as you would wish to be treated yourself
or in the Jewish and Confucian versions
don't do to others what you would not
like them to do to you and this requires
that you look into your own heart
discover what gives you pain and then
refuse under any circumstance whatsoever
to inflict that pain on anybody else
don't do to others what you wouldn't
like them to do to you and they've all
insisted that this is the essence of
faith that this is the test of true
spirituality not correct belief or
adopting the correct sexual behavior or
a certain political behavior it's or a
ritual practice
it is this essential thing and Confucius
who is the first person as far as we
know to formulate the golden rule said
you do it all day and every day all day
every day not just doing as we often say
well that's my good deed for the day and
then you can return to your ordinary
life of greed and selfishness no you do
have to make that act of empathy with
the other absolutely reflexive and if
you can do that our people have found
that you develop a new piece you
encounter within yourself and within the
other person a sacredness and a
transcendence and it is that that brings
us into relation with the doubt there's
a very good story that shows how central
that is associated in the Jewish
tradition with rabbi Hillel the older
contemporary of Jesus and one day it
said a pagan came to Hillel and promised
that he would convert to Judaism if
Hillel could recite the whole of Jewish
teaching while he stood on one leg and
Hillel stood on one leg and said that
which is hateful to you do not do to
your neighbor that is the Torah and
everything else is only commentary go
and study it now at a remarkable and
provocative statement and everything in
the Torah
that's the exodus from Egypt the
creation of the world in six days the
613 commandments of the Torah all this
is only a commentary on the golden rule
and Jesus said Paul made the same point
when he said I can have faith that moves
mountains but if I like charity it's
worth nothing
look the Golden Rule lies at the heart
of every religious and of every ethical
system of morality it's what makes us
look at one another the religions have
all adopted it independently our Chinese
Indian Muslim Christian Jewish because
they find it works because it says
something very deep about the structure
of our humanity this is the way human
beings work and if we do it consistently
all day and every day not when we just
happen to feel like it but even when
it's utterly inconvenient or it goes
against our self-interest then if we do
that consistently we discover an
enhanced capacity of human mind the
trouble is that most people don't and so
one of the reasons why I started my
charter for compassion was to bring the
Golden Rule back to the center of
religion and morality and not put other
secondary goals less demanding goals
into the into the forefront
well look this is a huge question but it
seemed to me for a long time that unless
we now learn to implement the golden
rule globally so that we treat all
peoples all nations whoever they are and
however distant they may seem to us I in
terms of at a distance or ideology as
though as we would wish to be treated
ourselves we are not going to have a
viable world to hand on to the next
generation we are now linked together as
never before
electronically financially economically
politically what happens in Afghanistan
and Gaza today can now have
repercussions in New York or London
tomorrow it's no longer trouble spots
are over there we are all bound together
and yet our world is deeply polarized as
ticket in a huge imbalance of wealth and
this is both a religious and a moral
problem that your concern as all there's
a huge imbalance in power and that has
resulted in the alienation rage Furion
and awful amoral terrorism that has
erupted that is erupting at the present
time and in order to counter this we
need to make the compassionate voice of
religion and morality of dynamic force
in our world and often I've been
frustrating to me as a historian for
religion that the religions which should
be making because of their ethos of the
Golden Rule a major contribution to this
me crucial endeavor of our time main
task of our time are often seen as part
of the problem and often when religious
people meet together or they talk about
his doctrines or I want to change that
and the more aggressive our ideologies
become the more aggressive our discourse
whether it's in the United States from
Washington DC or whether it's from
Tehran
or from some underground al-qaeda cell
the more aggressive that this was is the
more people of moderate persuasion have
to organize and speak a voice of
compassion that means to feel with the
other that doesn't just mean that we all
fall into each others arms this requires
a dedicated practice in order to always
treat others as we would wish to be
treated ourselves we have to learn about
each other not just relying on an op-ed
piece we may have read here or a
half-remembered interview on the
television program there that happens to
chime with our own views we have to make
a disciplined effort to find out what
our governments are doing in these
various parts of the world and what is
actually happening we have to learn to
listen to each other's stories some
things we're not very good at we're a
very opinionated society we're very
happy to spout forth our own views we're
not good about listening and we have to
listen to other stories learn to listen
to the stories of the terrorists just as
we hope that they will listen to ours
because very often these narratives are
express frustrations fears and anxieties
that no society can safely ignore as st.
Augustine founder of the Western
Christian tradition said that if a
biblical text seems to teach hate and
violence you have to give it an
allegorical interpretation and make it
speak charity even if this distorts the
meaning of the original biblical author
and the rabbi's in the Talmudic age do
the same somehow this has to be
orchestrated and now we've got on board
in the Charter at this moment about 140
partners worldwide with they now have
their own website and in these people
have all been working on this but
independently in isolation now we can
all work together and create a global
grassroots Network thousands of people
are signing on to the
online and that means an act of
commitment we'll keep them informed we
want to create
never mind the leaders or bishops or
chief rabbis or Imams or Pope's we want
to create a grassroots movement where
people will become attuned to
uncompassionate discourse in the same
way as we're now attune to sort of
gender imbalance in our speech I was
reading a book the other day where
people spoke about man and mankind
now that's offensive now we we're
attuned to that I want to give people an
ear to to that I want to create a rapid
response team right around the world
perhaps starting originally with our
partners similar to the one we have in
the United Nations whereby when there's
a problem in our society which your
demands a compassionate response an
educated informed not just a splurge II
emotional thing but an informed
compassionate response that puts
yourself in the position of the other
and sees all sides of the problem not
just your own there'll be somebody
poised in each society who can write to
the media write an op-ed piece go on TV
or radio
it wasn't so much as strong with faith
and doubt that attracted me it was
something else at the time I was
studying for my doctorate studying the
poetry of Tennyson I was suffering from
temporal lobe epilepsy it's a form of
epilepsy that derives from a brain
injury that I probably received at birth
there's a big scar on my brain that
gives you all kinds of weird and strange
psychic experiences and I thought I was
going mad I they wasn't diagnosed until
I was 34 years old people just dosed me
with antidepressants which didn't touch
thee this this brain disorder and I
recognized that in something similar in
Kennison and years later I discovered
that he too had suffered from temporal
lobe epilepsy and that he too asked it
his whole family a sort of familial
thing it was a great disgrace in
Victorian society epileptics was shut
away in asylums so he kept it dark but I
could experience I could see certain few
states in his poetry which was similar
to the some of the rather disturbing
experience as I was happening having
myself
illness itself can make you angry
enraged furious and it made me angry
enraged and furious I don't think it
brought me to God at all it depends how
you deal with it and I think that at its
best three little words that always have
to be applied to religion religion can
help you to deal with that not by giving
you some facile story about how you'll
Jesus loves you anyway and you'll soon
be reunited with everybody upstairs but
helping you to do some serious work on
yourself on your psychological work on
yourself helping you to deal with your
fears helping you and not to exclude
other people but to let them in on your
sorrow help you not to sort of sink into
a morass of self-pity and egotism and
that's a continual challenge but and it
doesn't just come with singing a couple
of hymns this requires hard discipline
serious work and if you sit lightly to
ego I'm not at the stage yet I haven't
had to say but I'm still struggling
towards it but if you don't teach
yourself day by day all then everyday as
Confucius said to sit lightly to ego
putting it ego on the back burner and
putting yourself in the place of another
it doesn't seem quite so terrible when
you get ill yourself
I think there are two examples which
show that I can think of many examples
which show how to die well one is
Socrates who is condemned to death
unjustly by the Athenian democracy and
he isn't forced to swallow the hemlock
but there's no rage in Socrates he no he
could have escaped he chooses not to
escape he swallows the hemlock he is
thinking all the time of other people he
washes his body to save the women the
trouble he jokes kindly with his jailer
he doesn't reel against him and he sits
and accepts the loving companionship
with his friends as he drinks the head
they have love it there's no rage
there's a big accepting kindness and
that was not just because Socrates got a
blast from God at the end but because
his whole life had been about facing the
unknown preparing for this moment
sitting loose to life and ego and lifts
emptying himself compassionately in
dialog with other people in a Socratic
dialogue the kind of conversations he
had with other people nobody won the
argument everybody realized that they
knew nothing at all and that they
listened and it always had to be
conducted throughout with gentleness
there must be no anger or malice and
that endless discipline throughout his
life enabled him to face this unjust
death and the other one is Jesus who on
the cross in the depths of agony is
presented by the Gospel writers as
having time to have a kindly word for
one of his fellow victims to make
provision for his mother and forgive his
executioner's but again we don't know
much about Jesus's disciplines but he
had lived a compassionate life it won't
just come at the end
I've just seen my mother through her
last years and a lot of
of the distress that she'd experienced
and I've came to the fore in the end
things that she hadn't really dealt with
we had now is the time to prepare for
death the lot of the religions say that
life is a preparation for death which
sounds morbid but our extinction
something we find very very difficult to
cope with the idea that we're not going
to be here anymore and that we've got to
go through as the Buddha always said
sickness old age and an undignified
death he himself suffered a death of
dysentery in some jungle miles from his
friend and died saying comforting his
comforting his followers saying don't
worry about me you have got in yourself
the means to go on thinking of them and
I'll tell you one personal story if you
like of somebody who was dying and who
made an immense impact on me and has
made has remained an icon with me when I
was a young nun we were trained quite
abrasively
people who read my story always think it
reminds them of boot camp in the army
and you don't expect your sergeant major
to be full of compassion towards you
he's supposed to be training you to face
fire and to be tough but I had one
superior who was kind and she had a room
life at the age of 29 she'd gone deaf
and hurts was had a very good mind but
she'd spent all the intervening years I
think some like 43 or 30 or 40 years are
sewing mending sheets in the laundry
you'd think a waste of a life and
anybody else could have come rageful and
bitter but she didn't and at the end of
her life she was dying all the year when
she was training me she was dying of
cancer when I arrived in her community
she'd been given the three weeks to live
but she lost is the holy
she refused to take any painkillers
because she said they would make her
head Muzzy and she was dealing with
young people and had to be alert for
them now you couldn't put her on a
pedestal because she was really quite
eccentric in many ways had many kind of
quirky eccentricities she was ten used
to get furious if we broke things and as
a result we were all so nervous I've
never broken so many things in the whole
course of my life but I was beginning to
realize that I was going to have to go
and my body was telling me already I was
starting vomiting sickness nosebleeds
all psychosomatic symptoms that I was
going to have to leave the convent but
she was always so kind then came the day
when they were going to take her away to
the mother house to die and she was in
bed very full of pain skin and bones we
all went in us young downs to say
goodbye to her and she smiled rather
like Socrates and joked with us and said
she'd been looking down from us on
heaven and you know she'd be dead soon
and all the rest of it sent us out and
she asked me to come back and I went and
knelt by the bed and she said sister I
always I was told that you would be a
troublesome
young woman I want to tell you you have
never been in trouble to me you've been
a good girl sister and we always
remember I told you so you are a good
girl and then she put a handle on my
head and blessed me and I went out now
for someone in an extreme of agony to
take notice to no doubt a rather
annoying young woman a troubled young
woman in that moment of extremity I've
never forgotten that
but that's she had trained herself
through all those difficult years not to
become bitter not to think why me why my
deafness why am I wasting my life
and as a result she's remained in me as
an icon of what a good person should be